[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro du cetud culture et tout
de suite le sommaire de ce mercredi 21
mars
ambiance celtique à la merise de trappes
pour un nouveau fest-noz le cercle
celtique c'est isabelle est toujours au
bombarde le samedi soir chants et danses
bretonnes vont rythmer ce week end on le
connaît comédien et chroniqueur françois
morel est aussi chanteur l'artiste
rendent hommage à la vie et au music
hall il était au prisme samedi dernier
et sa passion c'est le rock nicolaï
samson et un jamie blinois récemment
découvert dans la saison 7 de the voice
l'année 2018 a débuté avec la sortie de
son tout premier rhdp et ans débute ce
magazine avec un moment de patrimoine de
chantier de restauration de la chapelle
royale du château de versailles vient de
connaître une nouvelle étape lundi trois
statues ont été enlevés de la toiture
nicolas d'embûches la statue d'un
angelot dans le ciel hivernal de
versailles une sculpture déplacés du
sommet de la chapelle royale du château
une opération à l'aide d'une grue de 70
mètres de haut dans le cadre de la
restauration de ce bâtiment historique
un chantier lancé il ya un peu plus de
six mois c'est un moment très émouvant
parce que c'est d'abord très délicat
comme opérations et puis ces groupes
vont partir en restauration
pour le reste tout ce qui reste sur
place qui va être traité c'est la
maçonnerie la pierre de taille des
sculptures les vitraux les vitraux vont
être déposés également les ossatures
métalliques la charpente et la
couverture
au total trois statues ont été descendus
elles forment la sculpture appelée trois
enfants autour d'un palmier une oeuvre
de guillaume coustous et pierre le
poteau réalisé au début du xviiie siècle
qui va connaître un lifting d'un an dans
un atelier une restauration de temps
premièrement restauration des armatures
internes justement avait remplacement de
ces armatures trop altérés puisqu'on est
en présence de statut en plomb qui sont
creuses dons pour pouvoir les maintenir
en place il faut qu'ils aient des
structures internes métalliques
donc nous allons restaurer ses
structures internes ou les remplacer le
cacher et ensuite restauration de
l'épiderme du plomb le chantier de la
chapelle royale ne fait que commencer
coût global de cette restauration 16
millions d'euros financé par des mécènes
les travaux devraient être finalisées
d'ici trois ans cornemuses bombardes
guitare de soir pour fêter la bretagne
ce week-end c'est le fest-noz la fête de
nuit des duos des quartets des bagad ils
sont tous à écouter à la merise de
trappes et pour en parler avec nous
christian etienne le vice-président du
cercle celtique c'est isabelle bonjour
alors c'est une programmation très riche
encore cette année riche très riche
parce que les musiques sont variés en
bretagne surtout au niveau 2
des groupes musicaux parce que le groupe
leader qui veut passer la merise samedi
soir mélange des instruments modernes
les instruments traditionnels et puis on
va aller vers des couples de sonneurs
qui est la tradition en bretagne c'est
que vous avez un joueur de bombarde et
le bio et ça au rendez vous qu'il ya
déjà plus de 20 ans s'est élancé en 96
et c'est la 23ème édition
donc c'est à dire que la musique
celtique pour les bretons maintenant
tout à fait c'est il ya beaucoup de gens
qui ne sont pas d'origine bretonne et
qui adhèrent à cette culture et
c'est
du finition comme on l'a dans le cercle
celtique c'est abel de traces c'est
d'accueillir toutes les personnes qui
aiment la culture aussi la joie oui
voilà c'est un plaisir d'être ensemble
en plus voilà ce sont beaucoup de danses
collectives parce que voilà les danses
paysannes était faite après les travaux
des champs et on avait eu pour habitude
de se tenir par le bras
voilà c'était la connectivité non non
ils sont autonomes totalement autonomes
nous on est on est pris à d'autres
tâches c'est beaucoup de danseuses sont
aux crêpes
moi je serai à l'accueil sur le parking
dans la première heure
et puis d autres personnes sont dans la
salle pour organiser le faisceau a
annoncé des groupes qui ont passé sur
scène et bien d'autres tâches et cette
année donc ça se passe le 24 mars et il
ya sept groupes et artistes
la fonction de la composition alors il
ya vous interrompez si je me trompe sur
la prononciation casse-dalle gagnent
bull à ludovic rio daniel le fait on
erwan mengi 10 zajal aux subtilités la
petite prononciation le bagad kiz avel
ils viennent tous de 50 en une alors non
ils viennent de pour la plupart des duos
sont des groupes de bretagne
et puis vous avez cité quelques
personnes qui sont bien connus assez
havel qui sont repartir en bretagne
parce qu'ils ont pris pour certaines
leur retraite d'autres pour les raisons
de travail se retourner là bas et il
n'arrive pas à couper le cordon avec ses
havel ils reviennent se produire au
faisceau de train vous avez marient
entre eux qui a été danseuse et
musicienne chanteuse
à ces appels et qui a participé des
concours de danse avec nous et qui
revient chanter avec ça sent le duo on
va dire l'arrivée c'est un rendez vous à
ne pas manquer
j'imagine en parler juste avant des
missions parfois jusqu'à 500 personnes
qui se déplacent le
la plus grande capacité comme les power
c'est avec l'historienne du ya quelques
années mais les serviettes du historique
à vrai dire cela parce que la formation
a bien changé depuis et on a été jusqu'à
700 personnes alors en 2015 et un bagad
8,7 à vannes qui gagne un télé-crochet
celui d' incroyable talent est ce que
vous au sein de ces isabelle vous avez
peut-être eu un engouement pour la
musique bretonne des personnes qui sont
venues chercher pour s'inspirer de cette
tradition oui ça c'est chez des jeunes
quelquefois même ceux d'autres personnes
ça sollicite un petit réveil de fait
qu'ils aient des origines ou qui sont
sensibles à cette musique et qui intègre
la formation de musique quand on a qui
sont donné bénévolement vont il ya une
cotisation pour l'association mais qui
sont donné bénévolement par des sonneurs
de ces appels à l'école de musique de
trappes tous les lundis soirs sont des
danses rigoureuse et exigeante qui
s'apprennent très vite pour certains ça
prenne très vite parce que quand on
accueille les jeunes à la rentrée de
septembre
on peut dire qu'on leur apprend à peu
près jusqu'à cinq ou six danses d'un
premier trimestre et pour les meilleurs
ça peut aller au delà pour qu'ils
puissent participer au fest-noz voilà
qu'ils puissent s'intégrer facilement
dans cette soirée on en vient très vite
à danser alors cette année c'est une
double soirée à la vôtre le samedi 24
mars et le vendredi 23 mars à la
mauvaise idée aussi le celtic social
club
oui joue donc c'est une volonté de
francisco soeur et la brise et qui
voulait que marqué ce week-end de la
culture celtique
parce que il trouve que d'autres
présences attrape une forte connotation
parce que ma evry fille tellement la
création du cercle et du du fait qu'ils
aient une présence bretonne très
importante du fait des du dépôt de
locomotives qui avait à l'époque et de
la gare de triage de trappes
merci beaucoup christian etienne alors
pour découvrir un peu plus de la culture
bretonne le fest-noz de 16 avec des buts
à 20h15 samedi 25 marques 24 mars
inoubliable membres des deschiens le
comédien françois morel est aussi un
chanteur sur scène il rend un hommage
facétieux au music hall et à la vie
l'artiste était au prisme d'elancourt à
samedi dernier nicolas landry pour les
images
[Musique]
je pars tout perdu
ce matin
suspens
françois morel vous raconte des
histoires celle d'une vie de plusieurs
vies le comédien devient chanteur et
célèbre la vie en jouant avec tous ses
aspects l'intérêt d'un récital c'est de
pouvoir jouer un peu sur des
sensibilités différentes c'est un petit
peu les montagnes russes un spectacle de
chansons c'est à dire qu'on peut faire
une chanson très légère et humoristique
juste après une chanson plus pathétique
et puis revenir à une chanson comique et
c est donc celle eu le plaisir de jouer
avec les différents sentiments mais je
veux pas dire qu'il ya une seule source
d'inspiration en a plein un récital à
l'ancienne en hommage au music hall
accompagné de trois pluri musiciens
celui qu'on connaît comédien et
chroniqueur valent son humour et revient
à ses premières amours
quand j'étais jeune j'ai essayé de
m'accompagner à la guitare mais j'étais
pas très bon et ça me faisait très mal
au bout des doigts donc j'ai abandonné
la guitare et j'ai fait comédien et puis
après quand je suis devenu une grosse
boulette
non mais quand je fais une famille un
peu plus connue j'ai travaillé avec des
musiciens qui pouvaient m'accompagner et
donc j'ai pu renouer avec mon amour de
jeunesse la vie titre provisoire est un
spectacle fait pour les gens pour le
partage séance de rattrapage à paris le
4 mai prochain
la ville
son
et on continue soit 7,8 culture avec
notre nouvel invité un jeune talent et
viennois nicolaï chansons bonjour ou
alors vous avez tout juste 20 ans le
public vous a peut-être découvert ces
derniers mois sur une autre chaîne de
télévision parce que vous avez participé
à la saison 7 de the voice
mais pour vous la musique ça commence à
12 ans ouais j'ai commencé à 12 ans
c'est une histoire familiale je pense ça
vient de mon père qui a accusé de la
musique qui faisait beaucoup musique
donc voilà des dès l'âge de 12 ans il y
avait des instruments dans la maison et
je peux comprendre que vous y mettiez la
guitare sur ce que vous trouviez comme
on a tous les ans c'est ça c'est ça mais
j'ai un souvenir précis je n'ai pas fait
beaucoup mais j'ai un souvenir très
précis voix de j'avais pris une raquette
de badminton et j'avais joué sur de la
musique de muse et j'avais j'avais pris
beaucoup de plaisir un sage
peut-être que c'est ça qui m'a donné
envie après à 14 ans voulant c'est déjà
un groupe à peine au collège on va dire
en termes scolaire et vous lancez le
mmbb le montrent un vide musique bombe
puisqu'il existe toujours six ans après
il existe sans voilà le nom a changé
maintenant je joue souvent nico les
sanctions c'est pour des simplicité de
voilà de pouvoir est libre surtout par
rapport aux musiciens donc j'ai changé
de batteur mais j'ai toujours voilà le
même le même pianiste et le même
bassiste et voilà on continue de jouer
donc c'est pas c'est pas le même nom
mais on est toujours là alors je disais
tout à l'heure dans les titres vous
faites du rock pourquoi ce style là en
particulier peut-être amené par votre
voix à ces graves posées je sais pas je
ne sais pas si je me considère comme
rockeur en vérité je j'ai essayé
plusieurs styles depuis j'ai commencé la
musique mais le fait est que je me suis
laissée bercer par le rôle dans la
famille
et c'est ce que j'ai écouté est un jeune
c'était beaucoup de rock donc c'est sans
doute ce que j'aime plus faire mais j'ai
pas envie de me ranger dans une case
ouvert à tour des influences peut-être
des grands noms des grands artistes ou
des moins connus mais que vous avez
croisé la route qu'ils ont inspiré ce
qui m'a beaucoup inspiré moi c'était les
années 70 donc croiser la route n'ont
pas trop mais j'ai beaucoup aimé the
doors les beatles et s'il vous plaît à
lewiston mais mais mais plus récemment
angus et julia stone qui qui m'inspire
beaucoup dans ce que je fais donc voilà
donc en janvier
il ya quelques mois tout juste vous
sortez votre premier opus qui fait
partir de cet album lui on en parle d'un
tout petit peu plus tard justement avant
de parler de tout ça je propose qu'on
écoute un extrait le titre ces matchs
tropicale
[Musique]
pablo
félicite la vie
[Musique]
tu je te connais
sur le tissu
sochaux possible
je disais c'est un morceau tiré de votre
première rhdp qui s'appelle innocent
cinq titres longuement rêve mûri
peut-être réfléchir
on savait que 20 ans ouais ouais voilà
c'est j'ai beaucoup de plaisir à
composer à écrire donc j'ai composé
beaucoup de choses pendant un an et demi
deux ans et des choses voilà des
maquettes des idées que j'ai posées
dedans j'ai voulu voilà piocher cinq
titres il est maître sous forme de paix
pour voilà pour voir quelque chose de
plus propre c'est le sait pour moment il
est disponible sur les plateformes
digitales
moi je les en format où est ce qu'on
peut trouver sur le sur le site internet
on peut le commander
nicolas ils s'en sont point fr on peut
le commander et puis sinon dans la dans
la région des yvelines ya plusieurs
magasins je pourrais pas trop les cités
parce que je je je sais qu'il ya marée
sur mauldre des magasins que passer
mais voilà de 2 voilà il y en a d'autres
dans certains endroits
physiquement mais sinon c'est peut-être
mieux le commander sur internet
alors votre actualité c'est the voice
pour cette nouvelle saison alors
l'aventuré s'est arrêtée samedi lors des
battles que mika votre coach a préféré
frédéric longbois mais qu'est ce que
vous en retenez vous de cette cette
aventure déjà déjà le voilà le fait de
sortir face à frédéric longbois je suis
quand même assez c j'ai pas de regrets
parce déjà là dessus parce que c'est
quelqu'un qui a une très grande voix une
grande carrière une grande carrière
voilà il a comme ils l'ont dit dans
l'émission c'est quelqu'un de l'ombre
mais c'est quelqu'un que je respecte par
dont beaucoup pour savoir maintenant
maintenant voilà l'aventuré j'aurais
bien aimé qu'elle continue évidemment
mais je vois là j'ai passé un très bon
moment c'est son très bonne aventure
vous aviez choisi le mica comme coach
mais
j'ai lu dans la presse que vous aimeriez
bien chanté avec quelqu'un d'autre
j'ai volé peut-être un rapprochement
musicale une sensation plus c'est beau
c'est plus voilà si l'occasion se
présente et moi ça ne m'aurait pas ça
m'aurait pas dérangé du tout maintenant
maintenant voilà c'est aussi parce que
ils croyaient un petit peu en une
évolution dans l' aventure donc donc
pourquoi pas vous allez m'aider à la
mort voilà c'est ça donc j'aurais bien
aimé j'aurais bien aimé peut-être
pourquoi pas lui et lui écrire en tout
cas le remercier pour son soutien
une aventure comme celle sessad sans
doute sur la notoriété mais d'être face
à des artistes reconnus zazie florent
pagny pascal obispo milka et vous
apporte aussi un bagage il vous est
peut-être sur le placement de la voix
c'est bon je suis je suis peut-être pas
resté assez longtemps pour avoir
beaucoup de temps avec eux parce qu'on
est quand même beaucoup de candidats
mais c'est certain mais yahia il ya un
véritable ya un véritable échange
pendant pendant pendant les tournages et
voilà il apporte des conseils ce
principalement sur le sur le sur le
passage en lui-même
pas tant sur la voyais au réveil
auraient pas le temps il y aurait
beaucoup de travail ce n'était pas votre
première tentative vous avez essayé deux
ans plus tôt pourquoi on se relance dans
la première fois il s'était pas retourné
ça doit être aussi difficile
j'imagine à vivre est ce qu'ils ont pu
échanger avec vous après votre première
élimination en fait alors cessé la
production pour la deuxième la deuxième
fois ils m'ont ils m'ont appelé en
disant que c'était voilà vraiment
dommage que j'ai pas pu continuer donc
donc j'étais ravi de leur dire de leur
dire oui pour revenir donc donc voilà
ils m'ont appelé deux ans plus tard et
puis je me suis représenté voilà dans le
but toujours de participer pour la pour
l'expérience et laventure quoi si je me
trompe pas zazie vous a reconnu sa gym a
reconnu
vous avez quand même marié mémoire il ya
deux ans alors aujourd'hui une
collection il ya votre album
mais qu'est ce que c'est le futur pour
vous des scènes qui vont arriver
je vous rassure vous écouter voilà je
suis en train de jeter en train de
préparer j'ai essayé en fait de cet été
de tourner un maximum je vais essayer de
bouger le plus possible d'en france
parce que je j'ai beaucoup d'attachés
j'attends plusieurs endroits en corse
particulièrement en bourgogne aussi
et du coup j'aimerais j'aimerais voilà
aller jouer là bas pour les gens que je
connais qui m'ont découvert aussi j'ai
donc voilà cet été en juillet août je
vais je vais c'est ton et chant train de
préparer sa merci beaucoup une école est
venu en plateau à la ronde rappel vous
avez un album innocent c'est qu'on
retrouve sur le site
nicolas samson point fr merci beaucoup
merci
une prochaine fois on continue avec un
an un mot de rock à écouter à la
batterie de guyancourt il s'appelle
romain humeau le chanteur du groupe est
faible il est de retour avec un
quatrième album solo et on écoute un
extrait je viens chez mon coeur dans le
mythe naître le chances bleues de
l'homme à florent ta bouche tu cherchais
mon coeur dans les coulisses au délà
temps les
poussant la mort cette ombre là bas
c'est peut-être moins long
mosquée
n'allons pas dans le siècle quelle belle
religion toisant série braquo millénaire
qui cherchait manque
koné quand je crois que là
chip music comme chercheur dans un grain
noble d'une nature possiblement pas là
au café de la plage de maurepas c'est
une soirée métal qui vous attend trois
groupes du studio cobalt vous donne
rendez-vous car il ya acia et géo stigma
après la musique la littérature et
l'édition 1200 exposants et 3000 auteurs
présents sur trois jours le salon du
livre s'est terminée lundi dernier à
paris comme chaque année de nombreuses
yvelinois étaient présents notamment des
maisons d'édition indépendantes
une occasion pour elle de rencontrer un
nouveau public et de se faire un réseau
nicolas qui rit le vide c'est nicolas
d'andré se faire une place parmi les
grands et si possible se faire connaître
au delà des yvelines à côté des
flammarion grasset ou robert laffont au
salon du livre les maisons d'édition
indépendantes sont aussi présentes elles
sont un peu plus de 700 en ile de france
parmi elles inédit créé il ya 15 ans à
montigny le bretonneux et qui publie
tous les ans six ou sept romans on
échange avec les gens qui passent et qui
s'arrêtent devant nos livres et on peut
leur parler nos livres ils parlent de
leurs goûts de lecture etc
c'est aussi très intéressant d'un point
de vue professionnel pour échanger avec
les confrères
à part avoir une foule qui vont se
battre
ce faire signer votre nuage mais c'est
bien parce que bon
ça permet de rencontrer du monde aussi
ou de revoir des gens qu'on l'a pas vu
depuis très longtemps profité de la
notoriété du salon et de ses
opportunités c'est également l'ambition
des éditions versaillaise il adore à
quelques livres de la sa directrice
bénéficie elle aussi du stand mise à
disposition par la région ile-de-france
400 m² pour rencontrer un public
inhabituel porteur d'un autre regard tu
rencontres les publics qui dit ah ben
oui c'est que j'aime pas la couverture
ça peut arriver ça peut arriver en
décembre
à l'occasion de parler donc d'améliorer
aussi notre travail en moyenne chaque
année les français dépensent 116 euros
dans leur budget livres pour un chiffre
d'affaires de près de 4 milliards
d'euros une manne financière dont
profitent largement l'ile-de-france la
région accapare à elle toute seule un
tiers de cette somme
et cette semaine c'est marc il une poule
qui nous donne son coup de coeur on part
aux clayes-sous-bois bonjour cette
semaine à l'espace philippe noiret je
vous recommande parmi le flot de films
qui sortent un premier film qui est la
fête est finie de marie gare et le vice
donc c'est un premier film très fort
vibrant et juste avec une énergie très
communicative alors ce premier film est
porté à l'écran par de superbes actrices
notamment zita enroe que vous avez pu
découvrir dans fatima et qui d'ailleurs
a eu le césar du meilleur espoir pour ce
film et puis
clémence boisnard aussi qu'on a
découvert il ya quelques sont ceux d'une
qui va porter à l'écran l'histoire d'une
amitié fusionnelle et une renaissance
pour ces deux jeunes femmes qui vont
être confrontés aux tentations du monde
à l'extérieur et sortir de cette
toxicomanie avec toute l'énergie qu'elle
a qu'elles ont en elles donc voilà un
premier film fort et juste aidez moi
juste la renault clio chose n'importe
quoi je vous demanderai un autre pro 2
est quasiment impossible de brûler je
fais rien sans toi je sais pas si je
vous rends service
je crois que ça va finir comment
tu es en bas qu'ils ont gagné tous ils
ont raison d'agressions est toutes les
deux
du 23 au 30 mars et le rire soleil un
festival pour rire autour de raymond
devos
quatre spectacles sont proposés sur
quatre commune yvelinoise le mot les
risées eric bouvron enseigne la
direction artistique et on écoute
l'ambassadrice du festival elle était
l'invitée du cetud journal du mardi 20
mars
je pense qu'aujourd'hui beaucoup de gens
en ont besoin
c'est en même temps c'est on passe des
messages par le rire donc voilà c'est
important aussi de pouvoir donner des
formes différentes au rire puisque
effectivement les gens aujourd'hui la
vie enfin est difficile peut-être pas
mais en tout cas pas fait s'ils aussi
intéressante soit elle et c'est vrai
qu'avec le rire on peut passer beaucoup
de messages
une visite guidée inédite le musée de la
ville de saint quentin en yvelines vous
fait découvrir les coulisses de
l'immeuble
edison qui accueille notamment notre
chaîne tv 78 2 heures de déambulation
dans les locaux à faire avec une
réservation et autres et au théâtre de
chair d'elancourt le jeune ali reçoit
une leçon de géographie un garçon de 13
ans qui ne connaît que le sable la
poussière et le vent sec
un conte à découvrir samedi 24 mince la
compagnie pyramid imagine sa danse comme
un poème chaque mouvement est une lettre
dans un index les livres prennent la
poussière et les danseurs y mêle danse
hip hop mime et détournement d'objets
regarder
eric a fondé rupture à domicile une
agence pour rompre à la place de l'autre
mais sa nouvelle victime n'est autre que
gehl l'amour de sa vie un poker menteur
mené par olivier sitruk regarder on peut
rappeler son histoire et réussissent à
hauteur de quel canton qui quelqu'un
qu'on aime plus on n'abandonne pas on le
vit mais ont trouvé c'est compliqué
je suis presque telle envie de me voir
moi aussi est ce que quelqu'un est venu
pendant que j'étais pas là ravi de
rencontrer sylviane les amis des sondés
ta vie tu veux pas ça ne venez surtout
pas chez elle doit être doublé c'est
pourquoi je suis déjà sur place c'est la
fin de ce set fut de culture merci de
nous avoir suivis il est avoir retrouvé
sur le site internet de la chaîne tv 78
points comme et on se retrouve mercredi
prochain pour un nouveau numéro
[Musique]